hello reject nation I'm Greg Alva I'm
John so John what do you know we do on
patreon or for patrons what one of their
reward tiers depending on if you pledge
for this amount will write you a letter
beyond that I'll do whatever video you
request and put it up on the channel as
it's today's date still don't currently
have the channel back in our hands so
John and I we are going to do
Natalie Dorian's patron requests today
she recommended anything from the
BuzzFeed unsolved supernatural segments
interesting and we went with one that
could be a little movie related which is
the creepy real-life men in black are
these two guys you know watching men in
black I never knew it was based on truth
[Laughter]
as wearing black suits being
expressionless cool men and black women
only talked to two kinds of people those
who claim to have seen a UFO and those
who research of those they present
themselves as part of a secret
organization sometimes even producing a
white card with a crest and the word
security would and in some cases may
refer to each other right now
they brennidon scare people into
remaining silent about their UFO
encounters and ordered research think of
them it has the cleaners of the
extra-terrestrial universe although as
black do they actually where they look
like the men in black that we see in the
movies once they pull a part of their
skin did you know the basics here are
black dogs our dog was out on his boat
in the Puget Sound where he claimed he
saw six giant donut sheet objects in the
sky
well let the objects fell apart spilling
debris that killed his dog injured his
son he took photos of the debris but
said they were layer fogged over by a
man in black who told him not to speak
of the incident they had donuts in 1947
how old are done that's what he said he
said donut shaped objects in this bag
[Music]
[Laughter]
the object banished ridges into the home
a small lump of metal that he believed
was from the UFO well hi there
Richardson said he was visited by two
men in black suits he said the two men
asked for the piece of metal from this
site but wouldn't make isn't important
them that he'd turn it over for testing
they threatened
quote if you want your wife to stay as
pretty if she is then you'd better get
the middle back and Richardson never
heard from them again
it still has no idea how they knew about
the middle why don't he go to the police
why would he search on the internet what
do I think he may have gone to the
police there's no next encounter they
would stand across the street from their
apartment building they report that
apartment appeared to be rummaged
through and after seeing the street in
demand for three days in a row their
friend Timothy green Beckley decided to
get a closer look and managed to snap a
picture this is a rare instance that
were reported it might be common camera
how do we know he's actually dressed in
black if it's a black-and-white picture
it could be a dark navy these next
encounters I'm going to go over a little
more bizarre Jeffrey neering on
September 11th 1976
dr. Herbert Hopkins a doctor living in
Maine was studying a UFO incident when
he reportedly got a phone call from a
man
as a representative of a New Jersey UFO
organization the men asked it dr.
Hopkins was alone you know they can
review research dr. Hopkins agreed and
by the time he hung up the phone and
turned on the lights outside dr. Hopkins
claimed the man was somehow already
coming up the stairs to his door
Hopkins hit of the man is the most
horrifying yet a man wore neatly
tailored black suit was ball of Nilla
high brow so eyelashes and had smooth
and white plastic skin in his black told
hop gives a tank out of coil and it said
watch the coin after that Hopkins
Claypool quote it's starting to develop
a silver color instead of copper and
then the silver became bluish and the
penny was getting quite fuzzy
out-of-focus blurred and then it simply
was God
absolutely D materialized well I didn't
quote after that Hopkins said the man
ordered him to destroy his UFO research
counters like this if they were real
they would not be this interesting if
you tell the story no one's gonna
believe you first off and second off
you're gonna look like a crazy person
this next encounter is what someone you
probably know dan Aykroyd yeah it wasn't
that ghostbusters
the TV show called as good care of
sci-fi Network they went break serious
ground on a wide range of topics in an
alien video landscape in the middle of
conducting further interviews for the
show Dan stepped outside for a break
where he reported seeing black Ford
sedan appear suddenly across the street
Dan reports that one large man in black
got out of the car and came down a dirty
look Dan said he looked away for a
pretty second and when he turned back
the car was gone
two hours after the car disappeared dan
was given bad news from the producers of
the show Dan said quote we were told we
were not to continue taping and the show
was cancelled and none of them would
have why is it some weird alien
organization if that were to be true
that would mean that the government is
in accordance what these aliens are
ready so the men if I could show up at
Obama's that's gonna be like hey stop
looking for aliens but I've saved the
best encounter for last October 14 2008
newspaper fault hotel manager Shane so
far along with a hotel security guard
reported seeing a large triangular UFO
outside his hotel a group called the
aerial phenomenon and investigations
team looked into the incident they
reported in a couple weeks later
according to three other witnesses - and
identified men in black - visited the
hotel the men in black terrifying the
hotel staff and we're looking for Shane
so far in the hotel security guard
we're luckily not there at the time and
when Shane soap are reviewed the hotel
security footage he discovered that the
camera had actually caught two men on
tape what we're about to watch is that
footage no one's gonna die are they
so far reported that the witnesses
described the men as tall with black
suits black hats identical faces
extremely pale skin no eyebrows no
eyelashes in abnormally large eyes a
woman who spoke with the men claimed
that she felt that the men knew what she
was thinking is this video proof that
they might be exist or is this video
simply a big hoax can I be honest oh
[Music]
look they look the same that one pixel
it's so blurry you look at this [ __ ]
this guy right here the [ __ ] guy
standing next to the door okay looking
him next to him unless he's super tiny
with basketball players aliens you might
be actually unfortunately in most cases
of UFO or alien encounters come in form
of first-person accounts and it might be
different do they exist are they from
the government are they even human
ultimately it comes down to what you
believe me personally I believe that
while they may not be alien
even I can't believe that I do believe
that there may be a government agency
out there that would regulate these
things the permit mass hysteria I can
give you I can buy I've advised the fact
that the men in black may be a real
thing but I cannot give you the
satisfaction that they are covered up
aliens there are certain things like
ghosts or aliens or demons that no no
I'd say if those exist then that becomes
part of the science and there's an
explanation behind this they just were
logic questions where we'll always
disagree because not everything can be
explained by science always but one day
it's gonna happen and trust me sir I
will be there and I won't even say
anything I'll just smile at you like
this
all right the other Jews got amazing
teeth Ryan it's got great some Asian guy
yeah yeah it does
that was really charming and also very
unsettling here's my theory I think they
both believe all of it yes I think
they're doing these comedy in-between
banners because they don't want the
video taken down they don't want the MIB
to show they don't want the MIB to show
up at YouTube and force them to take all
the YouTube down that would be my theory
all seriousness though I've never seen
this segment before but first I'm seeing
it and you know we see a lot of these
top five videos or whatever that are
spooky or creepy and a lot of the time
you've gotta be questionable or they're
doing their best to convince you that
they themselves believe this is real -
yeah I like this shift in tone word yeah
spooky and scary you're like they have
it's like banter just do a couple like a
little bit based ever we just saw
they're diffusing it
yeah the reality of this of the
situation I think the two of them
together are great I love the banter I
love the balance of the comedy with the
draw it's a great show yeah it's a great
show I want to see more i watch i watch
more of my own this is this is a great
segment yeah thank you Natalie you know
terms of these stories though I didn't
know there was a concept of the men in
black themselves were aliens I didn't
think of that
I hadn't heard the more outlandish
stories about plastic skin yeah I always
thought it was more like there's a
shadowy government organization with you
know dudes who probably are like deadpan
because of who they have yeah and
probably nondescript looking
intentionally so people don't remember
their faces and describe them or
whatever that I can fathom but it's so
spooky I was talking with a couple of
people the other day once in Colorado
and once from Chicago and they were
telling me how they're actually they get
scared of like homeless people out here
who's gonna relate they get scared of
homeless people out here because out
here in LA we got a lot of crazy
homeless people they seem actual like
crazy and believe all kinds of crazy
things and say the nuttiest things and
yell a you and are aggressive they're
the kind of people who would tell you a
UFOs
and apparently where these two people
were from I was talking to you they
don't really see homeless people like
that you hug the homeless we don't so
when I hear stories like this most of
the time there's a part of me that but I
believe aliens exist I believe there's
other life-forms out there probabilities
so I'm not yeah but then again it's like
maybe some of these stories are true
maybe they're not the one that almost
got me was Dan Aykroyd story yeah but
yeah then I thought about Dan Aykroyd
yeah what do you be able to even get
this story out yeah just show up again
it'd be like seriously yeah exactly
but at the same time I mean if that's
true that's that's spooky
it sounds something like dan Aykroyd had
a show that got canceled and then he
blamed it on this yeah hiding a disaster
yeah you know the guy from blink 182 is
like a UFO gist okay and like is working
with the government to like find aliens
stuff mm-hmm
and there's places in the government
where alien is at least an idea where
they're like looking at it and thinking
is this real or should we look into this
who's got a really weird shadowy oh yeah
absolutely
cuz masses t they point out mass
hysteria and I'm like yeah you've got
some kind of crazy piece of otherworldly
metal or something yeah that might cause
a stir I don't know I mean maybe not
dad's specifically I think that you
could actually make a pretty solid men
in black reboot it could either be
really crappy or really cool if you went
for a little bit more of the tone of
this a more realism type of approach to
with men and black existed what would
they really be long dude okay here's
here's what you do you Center it on a
guy who's like really looking into alien
UFO stuff okay and so he keeps seeing
this dude in a black suit and you
started the first half kind of like a
suspense almost like a horror movie like
it's spooky you know like these stories
are yeah make the men in black a mystery
yeah it keeps popping up and key ends
like making the lead character more and
more on edge and then finally when they
when they meet when they like really
meet then it's like you're getting
really
close to the truth and now is the time
for you to either drop this or you're
gonna join us see you know hmm
and that could be a cool reboot a minute
black because then it's so like it's
still you know agent J's gotta join but
now it's like a different kind of movie
yeah call them j and k no probably
thinking hey and b10 you could change it
to numbers that'd be kind of cool
oh yeah they even said there were
numbers and some of the stories of their
names
do you think people deserve to know like
if some kind of crazy UFO alien piece of
evidence comes out or someone's
experience gets corroborated do you
think that they should contain that info
for a minute or do you think just
everybody should know I don't think we
should or shouldn't no different sort of
make them my life I knew what would what
would it do for me I mean is there a
reason that would change there could
create master perception good it could
and yeah it would change a lot but I
think it could also cause a lot of
problems at this point yeah that's what
I'm saying there may be like religious
wars again yeah some parts of the world
have religious wars obviously but you
know what I mean cuz I think about stuff
like this and it all sounds very
sinister but it is a difficult debate
you're like something like that they
would like abruptly blow people's minds
yeah like what would people do with that
it's like you don't want to suppress
information but at the same time it's
too much right that's weird
I don't know I'm glad that this might
not probably be true as I don't have to
think about it very much
yeah I could care less failings is it I
kind of would I'd like to know actually
I'm gonna dedicate my life I'm really on
the in-between the rest of my life
thinking they exist without knowing they
feel like people have known for hundreds
of years but I can't wait thousands
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell you can follow us on
social media especially download and
follow us in the Stardust Apple we do
30-second reviews for movies TV shows
and trailers and also become a patron
ejecta day just like Natalie Doran the
night la Dhara and Natalie Doran
she's going to be going to pubs
Christmas Christmas Eve Kristen
see Christmas Eve Christmas Christmas